my point is they so your family
found they found safety and Asylum and a
better life in the United States right
oh yeah absolutely so isn't there a
moral responsibility that those of us
who are descended from people like your
parents like my grandparents who found
that we don't have a moral
responsibility to make sure that others
experience that blessing as well because
there's a whole lot of people in the
world like that if we have a moral
responsibility to some wouldn't that say
mean we have a moral responsibility to
the to the world then that's a moral
responsibility to everybody on Earth no
not everybody's trying to come here
would even want to come here I imagine
there's a lot of people that want to
that but I I I think the answer is yes
legal immigration I'm sorry oh sorry I
was gon to say I was gonna agree I
believe the answer is yes however it has
to be legal